Philosophers love the burning building
scenario,
so you've got two rooms,
the building is burning and you can save
either the thing in one room or the
thing in the other,
and that's the choice that you have.
So imagine there's a child in one room
and there's a Picasso in the other.
The building is burning.
Now,
the effective altruist could argue that
you can sell up a casio for many
millions and with those millions,
give that money to charity to a malaria
net charity,
which will then save a great many on a
cost benefit analysis will say,
have a great many more children.
Okay,
so the effective altruism faced with a
burning Picasso and a burning child
might save the Burning Picasso.
Now this point,
my sympathy for effective altruists just
disappears and it disappears because I
think there really is something that is
not factored in here,
which is the emotional sympathy,
which is absolutely essential,
which you have done everything you can
to eliminate from our calculations,
but I would call the person and when we
disagree about this,
I mean I think the technical term for
the person that saves the Picasso,
and I think this would be a sort of.
I think publicly I would get a lot of
support for this.
Maybe not here,
but out there that the technical term
for the person that saves the Picasso
over the burning child is a heartless
bastard.